here's the one the only well Here I am
again winding up the ninth year you bet
your life nine years starting next week
we begin our summer series the beste
grotto
these are some of our best shows from
the past George who's on the first
summer show next week do you remember
yes billy appears on the jockey is gonna
be over soon yes that's right I had a
lot of fun with him when he was on our
show since then he won $64,000 on some
show I can can't think of the name of it
of course we're gonna have a lot of
other wonderful people on the show too
that we had on well I hope so and
remember it starts next week and tell
all your friends and tell Jack Webb I
will all right let's get on with
tonight's show we've got 15 $1,500 the
duck comes down if anybody says it and
you get $100 Groucho and Raul and Henry
Jacobs are standing by to talk to you
yeah uh-huh
folks you come in please a meet groucho
marx welcome for the DeSoto Plymouth
dealer say the secret word and you each
get an extra 50 bucks it's a common word
something you see a how'd you do how'd
you do Henry Jacobs
Jacobs is it there yeah Colby yeah
Jacobs Henry Jacobi and and Raul huh
and I'll start with you because you're a
woman where are you from Annie I was
born in Bainbridge Georgia hey Vaughn
and Jojo
yes are you married yes I have two
children you have how long have you been
married 16 years 16 years how'd you meet
your husband well we met in South
Florida had a motorcycle beach party I
hitched a ride with a another fella and
ditched and when I got there
you ditched a guy you went with why well
you see and I thought that if I stuck
with him I it would cramp my style yeah
you were on the back of the motor Sonia
you were pretty safe back there weren't
you
yes not much can happen to a girl on the
back of a motorcycle
let's see your your Henry Jacobs huh
that's right
Groucho you have an interesting stash
there a mustache thank you very much
I've been studying it ever since you
came up here I have one question to ask
you
yes why why do you wear it well you see
some people have told me that I look
better with it so I've worn it for that
reason I see well I've been told I look
better with my head in the bucket but
you don't see me wearing been watching
your show a long time brauch Owen I kind
of wondered about your mustache why you
wear it sort of it well I have no other
place to put it how you married Henry oh
no no no you're not married a mustache
like that you know maybe you why aren't
you married aren't the girls like your
mustache how do you pronounce it
moustache a moustache a moustache mr.
moustache
[Music]
are you are you from England no no are
you from Dixie no are you from hunger
some people told me well I think you're
very fine I can fellow bills Henry might
say the same thing about you George well
I don't mind being called George I got
mixed up there have been a number of
kings of England you know her name
George is true fat one who in the
Revolutionary War what a jerk he was the
whole continent because well I I was
born about five years after he was he
died do you have a job
oh yes Henry yes I do I have a small
film company in San Francisco we make
films for the television stations
oh really immerses professionally well
no then I have I have a radio program up
in Berkeley radio station we were in
quite a bit huh well Berkeley's right
next to San Francisco and we have a
bridge up there that you can go right
across it's very good across the border
but I mean yeah I have a bridge it costs
$300
well you're in a very unusual pair and
I'd like to go on talking to you but the
time has come to play you bet your life
here we go for the dictionary quiz you
can start with 10 all the way to 100 and
one answer between you your apartment
what do you want to stop home 100 all
right what is a hedonist 80 do n ist in
pleasure it's someone who devotes their
life primarily to the pursuit of
pleasure you don't have to go any
further you hit it right on the nail
with a thumb with a hammer
[Music]
walking rank start to have $200 now an
hour 90
all right synonyms avoids at the same
meaning what do you call words of
opposite meanings animals and did you
know that I've heard an hour lady an 80
80 dollar what is a massage of a person
what is the diva Sarge of a person V is
a GE
it's the face that show is showing now I
have 370 dollars now what 774 $70 what
is a system it's a well write $40 you
can't do better than that on this show
thanks and good luck from the DeSoto
Plymouth dealers thank you very much
[Music]
Dhokla mrs. Alice and lo mr. Albert Ison
are waiting to talk to you so folks G
Greene please and meet groucho marx
welcome for the DeSoto Plymouth dealer
say to say good wait and you each get an
extra 50 bucks it's a common word
something you always have with you
let's see Alice n Lo and Albert Eisen
hey where you from Alice I am from a
little town in western Colorado Grand
Junction Colorado found on the western
slope do you miss your old hometown did
you come out here to forget well I can't
very well forget it I have some claims
back there that keep reminding me Evelyn
that's why you came to California with
all these claims against you you must
have barely beat the sheriff to the
border what they happen to be uranium
plane really Oh Alice I happen to have
some oil stock that's absolutely
worthless together I think we could work
out a nice fast swindle would you be
interested in the partnership there I'll
tell you grotto
I'm a special investigator for the State
Corporation Commission I spend eight
hours a day five days a week
investigating those bad oil they are
well do you know what the fairest of
Toronto you'll find much of this
fraudulent activity in Los Angeles yes
there that's the statement of the month
it really is probably one of the main
reasons is that Southern California is a
mecca for middle-aged people and elderly
people who retire from the Middle West
and spend that time on the freeway the
fast line to Palace I admire the work
you're doing I think it should be
encouraged and I'd like to help you in
every way possible Oh would you happen
to have a list of these old people with
money
see I haven't got too much time and I'd
like to get started right away if I
could how I'll get back to you Allison
who we are you anybody that I should
know
Albert Eisen Groucho Eisen that that's
right are you in the stock business no
Groucho III where are you from I was
born in Los Angeles but when I was five
and a half years old we moved to
Torrance harness isn't that where it
rains all the time oh no Groucho don't
say that we're tired about those old
jokes like that you were gonna tell me
that joke that when it rains it pours in
Torrance actually what I was going to
say was that when it rains in Los
Angeles it comes down and tolerance and
you've got me interested in your town
where is it and what is it like that
Torrance is 22 square miles and we have
75,000 people are there many umbrella
shops and times we've gained 50,000
people in the last five years were
increasing in population at the rate of
a thousand people a month I think
doesn't rain there and you well it does
rain occasionally I guess you get that
admission how well are you no see yes if
I can go ahead we're a heavy
industrialized without it you have lots
of factories and they pay 65 percent of
our tax you're wasting your time
nobody's listening that kind of we're
building a new Civic cetera now why
you're so excited about this Hamlet well
Groucho I'm the mayor
[Music]
well I want I was wrong and I want to
apologize you're no small-time operator
you're the head of the mob well out
you're a good sport and I'm sure a good
man all right now let's play you betcha
life in the race for the $1,500 the
first couple won $440 now you selected a
spelling quiz this is an old-fashioned
spelling bee why do you want to start
with little ones are easy big ones are
hot yeah Wow yeah all right for $100
bail that live recklessly spell the
white fluorescent has in modern
fluorescent lighting one answer between
you now floor action didn't ya oh you
are esc EMT no I'm sorry mayor but it's
FAU Oh our PSC ent no a $50 now do you
want to try 90 yeah you can try easy
ones of you know all right spell the
word repetitious meaning continued RT
just repeating for epe t i TI o us yeah
right man that's right you know I have
$140 now what I'm not going to influence
you I want you to make your own decision
80 bucks
$80 spell conscientious meaning with
strict regard as to duty no empty
you know Co NS C ie NT IOUs yeah all
right man all right you now have two
hundred twenty dollars that was eighty
yes seventy this may make you a
gubernatorial candidate for $70 spelled
the word limousine meaning a type of
automobile usually chauffeur-driven
limousine Li MOU si any hell I am or you
si any that's right okay Daniel and you
wind up with $290 oh thanks and good
luck from the DeSoto Plymouth dealers
area
[Music]
gotcha Edna kitchen Hill and Wade Ruby
are waiting to talk to you so for to
come in please and meet groucho marx
welcome to you betcha live say the
secret word and you each get an extra
fifty smackers it's a common word
something you see every day
Edna Hill and Wade Ruby yeah where are
you from Edna I was born in the deep
south in the deep country in Louisiana
where are you from mr. Ruby I was born
in Coldwater Mississippi oh you're both
you're seven isn't ya neighboring states
don't need that so that's very how you
married Wade
yes grant you I've been married almost
25 years is that so it's a long time you
don't look at how'd you meet your wife
how'd you meet your wife
well there's not anything particularly
exciting about the way we met but we had
a very interesting honeymoon why why was
that were you married or two different
people at the time no watch Oh what you
think all honeymoons are interesting I
have an idea they are yes
yes the thing it made our honeymoon
night so unusual was the fact that there
was a raging torrent between us all
night
who was that was that her mother
no we were camping up in the Ozarks at a
little place called natural dam Arkansas
and been raining up in the hills and it
was a flash flood that came down
suddenly over the dam she was on one
side of the stream and I was on the
other and it was almost morning before
the stream ran down where I could wait
it you must you must have been run down
by that
if Congress isn't convinced we need
flood control this is so great you know
what Richard lovely said water has sunk
more grievances than wine always that
swim button I don't believe he's either
one gradually is a man named Meryl more
MORE
no I thought that was Archie Moore
wasn't it no I'm sure it was Lovelace
he's my favorite poet by the way he was
known as The Melancholy poet of the 18th
century now is there anything else you'd
like to know about Lovelace
I call him Dicky boy well is there's one
thing that you have right about Lovelace
that's his name that's astonishing here
he he was not an 18th century poet but a
17th century and he was not melancholy
but he was a Cavalier kind of a gay
blade stone walls do not a prison make
nor iron bars a key yes and renew their
minds innocent and quiet take that for a
Hermitage that's very pretty now were
you reciting this when the water was
going between
oh I think I was thinking of
Shakespeare's Tempest about boys yeah
well how do you know so much of our
lovely sir what is your racket you
haven't told us yet um chairman the
Department of English enjoys Pepperdine
College
you realize you're wrecking my only
claim the culture here don't you
I've been misquoting Lovelace on this
show for years well I'm undone Atlas the
coward dies a thousand deaths the brave
man dies but once right II might be and
as Byron said nothing ever happens to
the brave remember that you sure that
bara yeah yeah mrs. Hale the may I ask
your age you may but what I'd answer is
another thing I don't care you don't
care to answer well don't tell me oh I
don't mind
oh good you're 82
I thought you around 48 well um woman is
already she looks and a man is old when
he doesn't blow
now was that Lovelace no I don't know
the author now I think it was bugs bear
now Edna is that your name or even Edna
Edna DNA do you have any hobbies - while
away the hours oh yes I have plenty of
hobbies I'm a trained artist trained
artist yes I studied art I taught art
one time in a college what else do you
like to do if you say oh I raised funds
I a bonsai is our dwarf tree oh I
thought that was a bull's-eye how big of
these runs well I have a half of an elm
that's about this tall and if it had
been allowed to grow it'd be about 50
years 50 feet tall you know I have the
same hobby only I didn't know whether I
was interested in bonsais oh you didn't
matter of fact I have a tree that's over
50 years old
no no bigger than a foot now what do you
think of that it's a show tree
I hadn't trimmed it so much by now it
would be a closed free I'm sorry and I
didn't mean to be so hysterically funny
[Music]
this is the last stages the contestants
are striking back
professor what would Lovelace have to
say about this how are the mighty fallen
but that's not lovelies that's the point
David who was king in the land of Canaan
or as you say command yes 17th century
BC poorly getting it good tonight
well I happen to know another famous
quotation that fits it's from
Shakespeare who said how sharper than a
serpent's tooth it is to have an
educated contestant Lovelace let's find
out about your work just what are you
doing your job
besides embarrassing quiz masters I
teach I teach Chaucer
Shakespeare we taste choice of
Shakespeare why doesn't Joseph teach it
inside and I teach the Romantic poets
and editorial writing feature writing
and you'd be particularly interested in
next fall I'm beginning for the first
time a new course and humorous
literature is that so there's a crack in
there someplace
do you ever pick up any hot jokes from
your students there are they too busy
ducking class well I have a rather
interesting hobby of gathering
interesting answers to examination
questions could you give us one of these
pails well it was a history student who
was asked to name three results for the
Battle of Gettysburg and he wrote some
were killed some were wounded and some
weren't hurt at all
[Music]
well you know what the original joke was
no I am heard the question was how many
bones do you have in your body and the
kid answered 900 so his teacher says
that's taken me more than I have and the
kid says yeah I know but I sardines for
lunch
I may not know Lovelace but I know Joe
Miller way do you have a favorite among
the deaf he answers your students have
given you yes I saw teach English I
often think of the one that a freshman
girl wrote early in the fall when she
was taking an orientation battery of
tests she was asked why did you come to
college and she said I come here to be
went with but I ain't yet you know what
the original of that joke I don't
believe I know that the teacher says I
have went that's wrong isn't it and the
kid in the front row says yes ma'am it's
wrong because you ain't went yeah
[Music]
Johnson
well you're a nice couple and I'd like
to continue talking to you too but I'm
getting too educated so the time has
come to play you bet your life in the
race for the $1500 the first couple is
leading with $440 oh what a night you
have picking spelling this is an
old-fashioned spelling bee you get only
one chance at the correct spelling and
only one answer between you I want you
to spell the word and then pronounce it
and remember the more the question is
worth the harder it is now one answer
between you know what do you want to
start with 100 spell the word
vicissitude meaning a change or
succession as a change of fortune
vicissitude VI si si is si tu de now I'm
sorry there's only one seat all right
I'll tell you well you know how half
your original hunter you have $50 thank
you why do you want to go for ninety
ninety okay spell avoid pharmaceutical
meaning a medicinal preparation
pharmaceutical P har am a CEU t IC al
that's right that's right how did you
get all the C's in the right place that
time Oh trouble F time time $80 yes
eighty little ones you know easy let's
try it
alright says spell avoid acquiesce
meaning to consent agree acquiesce AC
knock it over first
AC q UI e SCE absolutely right professor
you now have $220
I I presume you want the $70 yes it's
your last chance to be the other couples
and talk it over spell the wire
therapeutic meaning to treat medically
therapeutic talk it over th e ra p EU t
IC that's absolutely right professors
absolutely and why not with $290 sorry I
lost the face when thanks and good luck
from the DeSoto Plymouth here
[Music]
that means mrs. Rolla makeups with $440
in just one minute get the chance of the
1500 on the question to Jacobs right
back in here please huh there's old
stash e again alright here we go for
$1,500 I'll give you 15 seconds to
decide on a single answer between you
think carefully and please no help in
the audience here it is Franklin D
Roosevelt saved the longest presidential
term in our history but for $1,500 can
you tell me who sewed the shortest
period of time
[Music]
what is it Andrew Johnson no I'm sorry
it's William Henry Harrison who saved
one month that's a shame
where'd you lost a big money how much
they win the quiz Joe they went all the
way on the quiz four hundred and forty
dollars
well that isn't too bad thanks for being
with us and thanks to all of our
contestants on the show tonight sorry
[Music]
and here's just a final reminder that
the best of Groucho starts next week in
our first guest will be jockey Billy
Pierson and John J Anthony so if you'd
like to see these people again I suggest
you tune in the best of Groucho next
week and here is the one the only
[Applause]
well here I am again with a chance for
each of our couples to win $2,000 and if
they're lucky they may even get a crack
at ten thousand penny bar couples say
the secret word the duck will drop down
and pay him an extra hundred dollars the
way tonight is head ok doc Peter all
right George whose face four desoto Jan
Dietrich and John Rose are all set to
Tatia Groucho so thought to come in
please and meet groucho marx welcome to
your betcha life say the secret word and
you each win an extra $50 it's a common
white something you see every day
Jan Dietrich and John rosy John Rose
that's a simple declarative isn't it I
believe so God - but the name is Reese
roee se Johnny Reese Tony race when you
spell it ro sa ro e se ro e SE well I'm
sorry to hear that Jan you're a mighty
pretty girl and I have a question to ask
you are you married no I'm not Groucho
how old are you Jan I'm 29 well you're
named after January no it's my full name
is Janet Oh Janice a nickname no I see
do you have a job Jan yes I'm a
commercial airplane pod pilot do you
look more like a hostess with the
mostess what do you like for Jan I'm
head of the flight Department for the
air Oasis company at Long Beach Airport
they are the largest distributor in the
world for Cessna Aircraft and Cessna is
the largest like clean manufacturer in
the world well that's enough of that
commercial
how much do you get for one of these
these planes they range from about nine
thousand dollars to about fifty six
thousand dollars fifty six thousand no
that's for the twin-engine five-place
Cessna 310
it's a beautiful airplane well I should
think so if I paid fifty six thousand
dollars for an aeroplane it would have
so many mortgages on it I couldn't get
it off the ground where are you from
Jan I was born in San Francisco and I
went to the University of California Oh
San Francisco did you know mr. Penniman
did you know that mr. Feinerman San
Cisco yes he's very well-known up there
that's why you had to come down here and
you are in rollers gradually
are you related to Billy rose no
graduates do Reese know related to roses
are red violets are blue horse horses
Nicki you said you're getting choked but
unexpected quarter
horse's neck to you huh why do your left
John graduate for the past ten years
I've been living in Azusa California
Azusa I thought that was a cracker what
made you decide to live in Azusa as
opposed to Paris or London well
gradually
why did why did you live that you just
love the town is that it forgot you and
I Jack Benny used to do a lot of gags
about Azusa on his program I heard so
many of them I decided to go out there
and look around and I found a lot I
built an adobe house on that's right
little know you're lucky Benny didn't
mention how to Mongolia are you married
yes got you I'm how long you been
married six months is this your first
time out yes yeah sure it is why'd you
go on your honeymoon did you go to
Cucamonga and no no you spent three days
of the convention illegals
they just fly around there much right
yeah I was a pretty busy man up there
and I didn't have much time to see my
wife but all hope she enjoyed herself I
think she did well could a moose go
there or Alka yes if he was an eagle -
why did you go - Annie goes convention
on your honeymoon
well because I'm an eagle
where would you have gone if you were an
elk going to an elf's convention oh god
maybe it hang over a fireplace well
let's get back to your plane's
Janet how much did you say they cost
they ran from about nine thousand
dollars to fifty six thousand dollars I
don't care they run the question is will
they fly what makes a plane stay up in
the air I never could figure it out
the lit from the air holds with the wing
up areas very dense what was that last
thing the air is what Dan well I'd love
to do you can at Walser
well I don't understand about at being
dense how dense is the air is that as
dense as the sucker who folks over
$56,000
well a bathtub full of air weighs about
two pounds I've never flown a one of
those I was sucked down the drain once I
don't I didn't know that that a bathtub
full of their way do you know when I
take a bath that was but water in it
do you understand what she's saying
mister yes I do good you do what would
you explain it to me I don't well Lou
wing goes over the lift I mean the air
goes over they lift of the wing over the
top and creates a vacuum underneath that
helps lift the plane and there's also
air underneath which helps push it up
well that's an eagle I guess you'd know
a lot about you're doing here
have you ever done any flying there
Johnny yes got you a little I had about
45 minutes of a stick and I was also a
stunt man on ol Jenny really did you
know oh yeah
Jenny airplane gets room I've done many
it's not with all Jenny
we had a high old time together
well I'd like to continue talking to you
about the Eagles and old Jenny but it's
time for you to win some money
so let's fail you bet your life well you
selected food and cooking right if you
miss two in a row you're out if you get
four in a row right you win $1,000 what
food is more widely grown and used than
any other food come on kids we
one answer wheat no it's rice well well
you're off to a flying start you got one
raw you get one more wrong and you're
out you can't get a better deal in that
any place all right now let's see what
you can do with it what kind of seeds
are used in rye bread one answer now
talk it over
hmm can you caraway seed
that's right caraway back to all
Virginia you're on the right track now
three more right and $11,000 what is a
ragout are AG o UT venomous - are you
referring to mr. Penniman or is this the
end that's right a ragout is a student
you're halfway to a thousand dollars all
right what are Jonathan's Gravenstein or
grabbing Stein's and northern spies
apples apples that's right one more
right you'll have a thousand dollars did
you know that a Gravenstein a day will
keep the doctor away all right how many
standard cups of granulated sugar are on
one pound
how many cups have you never been in
your cups mr. Reis market-leading how
many standard cups of granulated sugar
are on 112 okay take a guess two cups
two cups is right uh it was Warner all
right so you win $1,000
[Music]
you want $1,000 now you can keep it and
quit or else you can come back later and
try to double your money you might even
get a crack at $10,000 so go over there
and think it over no matter what your
decision is thanks for being on the show
thanks
[Applause]
here's the beautiful motion picture star
Jean Grae hello I'd like to show you
something I'm very proud of this is my
new DeSoto isn't it beautiful
it's long and lovely and long almost a
foot lower than I am and I'm only five
feet five I think its styling is
outstanding and these new fins are
really striking and what's more my
DeSoto is fun to drive even in heavy
traffic it's so easy to handle de Soto's
full time power steering is the best
I've ever tried
of course push-button driving is a
wonderful improvement it's so simple the
way my just sort of rides you just won't
believe it until you try it as you may
have gathered I'm very pleased with my
new DeSoto
I paid a lot more for cars but this new
DeSoto is the most exciting car I've
ever had it's the most exciting car in
the world today the 1957 DeSoto George
who is next for this soda gacho missus
Niner Morgan the mr. Niki Stewart are
waiting to talk to you so folks come in
please and meet groucho marx welcome to
you betcha live say the second white and
you each get an extra fifty dollars it's
a common way something you always have
with you now let's see Niner or Nina
what is your hometown
neither Napoli nah Italy oh you're from
Italy yeah yeah how long you been over
here ten years ten years what was your
reason for coming this country I assume
you had a reason I shouldn't have I had
I made a soldier I met him on a dance
hall in Italy yes I thought he went over
there to fight I guess DPS he thought he
was writing in a dance hall no no no no
no he was right after the word was over
oh he went right from the war to a dance
hall yes oh well no pull around this guy
he should then just drop his musket
[Music]
we've had war brides on our show in the
past you know and often they tell us
that they have trouble getting into this
country did you all know me I was one of
the 500 girls they came over anima and a
boat 500 yes well we're dry and their
husbands were on the boat too no sir but
we should have a good time
500 young brides all along all along
that crew mr work-for-nothing I'll bet
that's the only ship that ever ran out
of gas six times in the middle of a well
how'd you like this trip was it exciting
it was real excited but not as excited
that the last trip I made I wasn't made
another trip mm-hmm
and I wasn't even played or you know
their ship is sunk on the Andrea don't
you and it was Duncan its son I know
just how you felt I was in the stock
market when it sank in 20
well that's very interesting a survivor
of the Andrea Doria you were very lucky
I do when this disaster struck well I
was sleeping downstairs and when I heard
it under the boat not in bed oh and when
I heard the wreck and I run upstairs
with my pajama and we I have a clue in
my head you read well curl my head
[Applause]
[Music]
that's a gimme Wow Anthony Aiden
the audience is full of Egyptians here
tonight you said the secret wine which
is Kyle on my head so you get fifty
dollars and you get fifty dollars
thank you see how nice it is see now
then tell us what happened what I'm
curling your hair yes yes I had my cool
my head and I have just pajamas when I
went upstairs
everybody said I saw yes sighs so I went
to and I slide down then we got in the
line and slide down on a rope you slid
on a rope mm-hmm wasn't it pretty chilly
in the board yes and I was all I got all
wet some high don't know how but I will
it I don't understand I didn't see how
anybody can get wet in the ocean now
then your name is Niner Morgan that's
nice Oh your name is oh no your name is
Nike Stewart huh
Nikki state Oh Nikki's go to school
wearing a firm Nick I'm from the Bronx
New York from the Bronx what kind of
work do you do Nick well I'm a personal
manager I represent show people home
listen well I know what that is but
perhaps some of our listeners don't we
have a audience full of Egyptians here
tonight
did you tell us what a personal manager
does and also explain how is it you
managed to stay out of jail
well a personal manager is a man who is
supposed to project the talents and the
name of a certain personality that may
be on the contract to him he looks at us
for guidance guidance and we must always
act in a fiduciary manner I pick a card
that's mine give me that again I said we
must always act in a fiduciary manner in
order to protect our client well the
orange snow's what that mean but I don't
explaining that to me well you mean
fiduciary
yeah well fiduciary is a statement that
is printed on all contract personal
contracts which means that you must at
all times this is a very small print
yeah and it means that you must be
honest with your client and you must not
scheme for your own personal gains at
any time well how do you make a living
[Music]
supposing a personal man is you want to
steal an honest dollar here and there
miss glide how is that done well as I
say I've never done it but in the
question I give us up for instance you
make me sound guilty no no no I want you
to present purely a hypothetical case
all right
well in in the grapevine there are so
well you hear things like this there are
several unorthodox personal managers who
what do you mean they don't wear a hat
how they doing it belongs to the client
but what they do is they here's how they
would do it as I have heard for instance
if I were trying to get one of my
clients like Joe Venuti happens to be
one of my clients asked the owner or the
booking agent in charge for dinner and
probably spend a few dollars on him and
I would say that I spent $500 on
entertainment and when maybe I only
spend $50 that is tabbing and as I say
there are some of these personal
managers who are more or less in cahoots
and they do work things out like that
but I've never done this I'm sure you
have I'm sure you've never swindled a
client never never but it's pretty
obvious you've given us some serious
thought
[Music]
now let's say that you were my personal
manager Nick just how would you go about
giving me a one of those big build ups
well first thing I do for you
Groucho would be get you a brand new
audience how do I need a new audience
for well so what's the matter with the
one I've got now well I'd uh what I was
the trade-in value on this group well
what I mean I want to get a pretty good
trade in it because this audience has
only been driven by a little old lady
who lives in Pasadena well anyway what
did you do well I would I would put you
on I send you out on tour first of all
to the largest nightclubs in in the
country
I would project your likeness your name
and your personality and all high
schools colleges I would get you a new
audience a youthful audience the new you
can upgrade the new crowd the hoodlums
[Music]
they don't want and kind of a
conservative group of antiques like we
have it what makes you so sure that
there are lots of people who don't know
me well I'll give you a personal
examination this region groucho legion
that's my poem about about well several
months ago my daughter tisha she's only
ten years old and I was sitting in the
den and she came in and she has a little
raid at television in a room and she
called me she says daddy why don't you
come on in Jesus used to be in the
business I want you to watch the
brand-new comedian and I went into the
room to watch it and there it was the
Groucho Show so Isis and Isis this man
is funny but he was a star before I was
born
[Applause]
just a moment ago boy
how old are you I'd be 39 tonight you
tell your kid I was a big star before
you were born I just decided I'm gonna
hire you as my manager just so I can
fire you 10 seconds later actually
ten-year-old children love me bigger I
know they do and you know why cause my
show goes on right after dinner and they
don't have to do that homework how'd you
ever get under this off racket just
collecting money from talent well I
originally started out as a hoofer what
we call in the business Oh hope for us
me dancer
oh no Nina let's get back to you what
sort of interest do you have aside from
keeping us well I work in the coffee
shop that Bob's drive-in
I sell big boys you sell big boys wife
that's an incomplete statement what are
you selling they're big boys yeah I
think they always going it here huh I
bet a lot of people know what is what
what do you know what a big boy is uh
well it can be a large use isn't that
Lord Blair
it's a large use with a hamburger don't
call them burgers without allowed to sit
at home they big boys well that's like
on the airlines you don't need never say
it's rough they have a euphemism that
they use it stag Uhland this is the age
of the infamous immunity no such thing
as a an undertaker nobody buries you
anymore
you can die now get bearing you don't
know who did it it turns out to be a
what are they clearing out the
Undertaker well they have a fancy name
now well I can't think of it well is
that what you always want to do hawk
hamburgers well I don't have any other
ambition why should have I always to
have a stick or ambition I want to be a
dancer you want to be a dancer I always
want to oh well are you a good dancer
well how would you handle the situation
like this Nick mr. Garland wants to be a
dancer could you what could you do for
her well I'd have to see what what what
she could do in dancing look Ann told me
you used to be a dance yeah well I kind
of music could you dance with her
I sure could oh it's called a mortuary
I advanced whether if the boys would
give me some rhythm music you may name
you the musicians we have a loose
expression forever we call them
musicians what kind of music would you
require some type of rhythm used in Rome
some rock and roll yeah can you give me
some rotten
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey you to make quite a team what's your
opinion Nick I think she's really gone
yeah she no she still here but
well I'd like to go on talking to you
but now let's give you a chance to win
some money
you vote now how we play you bet your
life yes now we want one answer between
you and all these questions you selected
professions of famous people I'll ask
you some questions if you're Miss tuna
roll you're out if you get four in a row
right you win $1,000 you ready
what was the famous Nijinsky
professional duties well she touched me
in Italian he was a dance rubber that's
true he was a dancer one right three
more and you'll have a thousand dollars
now what was Hippocrates profession
remember the Hippocratic oath implicit
he was the father of Medicine II was
adopted oh yeah said Panetti doctor's
office you see that out that there the
Hippocratic oath one wrong now I don't
get another one wrong or you'd be out of
the game oh are you Republican what
profession is the name of Jacques fat
connected FA th J AC qu es capital F ATH
with what profession
an actor I'll just add his throw he was
a dress designer very famous movie money
got two wrong in a row so you're out of
the game
oh I'm sorry you missed two in a row so
your alter well we don't want you to go
away empty-handed I'm going to ask you
one question for honor dollars you ready
what was dr. Defoe's profession he was a
Hippocratic oath
I'm sorry didn't win war but you won the
sacred way that's a hundred dollars and
I hung up for this so you got $200
thanks for being with us
Terry didn't win more you bet your life
[Applause]
now in just one minute we'll find out if
our first couple mrs. Dietrich and mr.
Reese will risk half their winnings on a
chance at $10,000 now I'd like to show
you something important this is a
picture of the most exciting value in
cars today this is it the 5070 solo with
a new low price this year's DeSoto was
away ahead of our competitors and yet to
soda prices start right above the lowest
it's a big car with big car comfort um
big car beauty that our competitors will
be imitating 2 or 3 years from now it's
low lower than any of our competitors
but it's got as much or more room inside
as any of the cars that are much taller
and plenty of Road clearance too it's
really got power and terrific
performance and that new torsion air
ride is so smooth you'll find it hard to
believe then there's new triple range
push-button driving one or two cars are
imitating that now and others will
follow but this is by far the best now
I'm not telling you to run right out and
buy a DeSoto on my recommendation but I
believe he'll be a wiser automobile
buyer if you'll drive this car see what
it has to offer and price it and I think
you'll be surprised because this year
DeSoto prices star just above the lowest
and make your decision drive a DeSoto
before you decide
[Applause]
George where agency who's gonna get a
crack at all this money what's the story
on our face couple well as you know our
last couple didn't qualify but our first
couple did and they've decided to risk
half their earnings on a chance at
$10,000 and here they are Dan Dietrich
and John Reese yes right roses ladies I
think Reese are you ready
you decided to go over the big question
wherever you miss it you wind up with
$500 are you still going to go over the
big money okay there are 10 numbers in
this wheel I want you to get together
and pick a number any number you want
from 1 to 10 one of you picked the
number and 1 spin the wheel take a
number
there's only 10 5 give it a twirl
[Applause]
[Music]
your number was five and you landed on
self you ready
you got 15 seconds and one answer the
American soldiers named GI or Doughboy
for two thousand dollars one of the
British called their army privates
[Music]
what is the answer you've decided upon
tummies
Tommy is right Tommy Atkins
oh you win $2,000 congratulations and
thanks for being with us you bet your
life
[Music]
[Applause]
and now here he is the one the only
I wonder what became of Sally and
Groucho oh that's me
[Music]
well here I am again with $2,500 for one
of our couples a lot of money it
certainly is and even say the word the
secret way they duck I'll fly down and
pay him 100 bucks the word tonight is
the house okay scram Oh gotcha we have
some young single people for you they
were chosen by our studio audience just
before we went on the air
miss houla Anderson the mr. Charles
O'Brien Osbourne would you go in please
and meet groucho marx welcome welcome
for the DeSoto Plymouth dealer say the
secret word and you'll divide $100 at
the common way it's something you see
every day Willie Anderson and Charles
O'Brien husband you're both single
that's for you
you know each other no I've never seen
it before
don't be so happy about well let's get
acquainted shall we
I'd like to very much kula is that right
I thought I am pronouncing
no my name is Ulla Ulla good luck French
have a voice I know you're a French guy
yeah finish yeah big Swedish
no but I wish I did you're looking at
you I wish I could speak English
what part of a Sweden are you from
Minneapolis no I think I should speak
was that anciently could you could you
spell that for the audience well I can't
read it in English but I can read it in
Swedish because you don't have this
listed most balanced way nation and in
its core LD is being cool
now spell it backwards along you benefit
from Sweden one half year oh you speak
very good English did you speak english
in sweden well I took it up at school oh
how early you who are 18 well you're
very pretty Swinscoe
[Music]
the best advertisement for smorgasbord
I've seen a long time let me be great if
you could pick her instead of the airing
on this
what made you decide to come to America
was it well with lots of American
pictures also and it was still handsome
voice in those pictures and now that
you've been here why would you say these
movies were accurate and depicting
American men well I think that it'll be
too redundant don't you like I'm all
that down what do you want them rare
why don't you really expect over here a
lot of 60 million Gregory pecks you
realize what that is sixty million packs
is 15 million bushels
Charles O'Brien husband and that's a
pretty imposing name which one of these
three names shall I call you I'd rather
you call me chaired sir Chad that's
right sir how old are you Chad in 20 dad
let's see if you're a gay romantic
handsome typical American male what sort
of what do you do I work at a service
station
I'm good honest work is this your
ambition to someday own your own service
station and and service DeSoto's and
Plymouth no groucho my ambition is uh
further my ability to be a stunt man a
stunt man but I decide the station what
do you do hang upside no my gas
[Music]
what kind of a stuntman are you I'm an
arrow trapeze artist in a second know
that comes under the heading of the
airplane she I have a my trapeze bar
that I hook underneath the airplane and
then who a couple thousand feet and hang
by my heels and my knees oh that's not
so exciting I did that the last time I
flew eased it's called tourist ID class
[Music]
what else did you do that you just hang
there like a bat until the plane runs
out of gas no after you get through
yours through charities like the crowd
please they don't think you have a
shooter because you're up so high they
can't see it and to put this over pretty
big you hanging there but your heels and
all of a sudden you just fall and that's
a good joke yeah it really shakes the
people up you fall a couple of thousand
feet and you open the chute there you're
all relieved in yeah what do you think
what do you think of a lot well I think
she's a very nice pretty young lady and
she has a very cute accent yes she is
you ought to know you've been looking at
it ever since you've been up there
I think you should do it who should get
to know each other better
hula would you like to go flying with
Chad no I don't like to ride an airplane
well you wouldn't be riding in the plane
you'll be swinging up
[Music]
well you're a charming couple and now
you're gonna play you betcha life and
all of this is one part of America
you'll enjoy because you'll have a
chance to make a lot of money here we
start you off with $100 if you miss a
question you lose half of your bankroll
and you can quit any time you like
let's see how much money you can make
you selected music and remember the more
the question is worth it the harder it
is now what do you want to start with
don't care so just talk about $50 all
right let's see if you can identify this
well-known guy swing tune play jack
[Music]
[Applause]
now it's a very well-known song and some
brace about you by George and Ira
Gershwin well you lost half your
bankroll you'll still have $50 all right
now don't get discouraged what do you
want to try this time except you I'll
let you decide I've messed up on the
first with me 60 this tune has been a
favorite for years what is it sleep baby
time Gail is right your bankroll is
growing again I'll have $110 now what do
you want to try hmm go ahead 70 old
devil moon and how are things in glocca
Morra our two hit songs from what
successful musical comedy played on
Broadway for two years you can talk it
over you know well I'm sorry it's
Finian's Rainbow well you now have $55
$55 and is your last chance sad to beat
the other couples now what do you want
to try stupid brute go for broke get all
right with you hula yeah that's $100
let's go for 80k okay
al jolson and Vincent ruse wrote this
longtime favorite what is the name of a
play Jack
[Music]
come on oh you stunt man if you don't
know take a stab nothing
mm-hmm well it's they play it every time
you go to Catalina in a javelin and you
wind up with $27.50 well thanks and good
luck from the DeSoto Plymouth dealer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen this is National
Safety Month
can you see stairs stop safely if not
check your car check accidents with the
busy driving season here now is the time
to check your car be safe by driving a
safe car that makes a lot of sense
George last year over a million people
were killed and injured and needless
automobile accidents it's a dreadful
waste of life yes and the tragic thing
is Groucho that a great many of those
accidents would have been avoided if the
car owners had taken just a little time
to have their cars checked and to make
sure your car gets a complete safety
check-up there's no better place to go
than a DeSoto Plymouth dealer his
factory trained mechanics will go over
every part of your car that can affect
your safety to make sure they are all in
perfect working order wheels brakes
headlights tires steering windshield
wipers glass horn muffler tail lights
everything you need for safe driving you
know it takes only a small amount of
time and money to keep you and your
family safe on the highways isn't it
worth it remember to be a safe driver
you must be able to see steer stop
safely check your car checked accidents
stop in where you'll see the sign of
better service the friendly sign of your
DeSoto Plymouth dealer we have a high
school boy boy tonight watch oh he's
Henry Aaron and his partner is a very
special guest she's mrs. Laura Asher
well I don't think I'm gonna tell you
any more about her I'm gonna bring her
out here and see how long it takes you
to recognize her so uh folks do come in
please and meet groucho marx welcome
welcome for the DeSoto Plymouth dealer
say the secret word and you'll divide a
hundred dollars it's a common word
something you see every day
mr. Henry Aaron and mrs. Laura Asha a
mrs. Asher I gather there's something
about you Fenneman thinks I should know
I've got a pretty good idea already but
I'll give our listeners a chance to
guess Henry let's talk to you you're the
tallest how old leo well I was born in
1936 36 I see that makes you infant
poppycock democracy don't a boy TV show
how old are you 18
you're going on 118 oh well when you're
18 there's plenty going on do you go to
school
yes I'm a senior B at Fairfax High
School Oh senior somebody out there from
CCNY let's get back to you mrs. ash and
phantomon didn't fool me I know who you
are why aren't you in the movies yeah
about 20 years ago uh-huh at the time I
was in it what are some of the pictures
you were in oh dear I wonder that you
remember well name 10 king of the dress
yeah I'm talking about Y whole time
that's right and finders keepers captain
the canary Oh dozens of us I don't
remember Henry did you ever see mrs.
Ashland pictures well if she made
pictures 20 years ago I don't think I
could have seen her I'm only 18 don't
you watch television
when you're just as lovely and charming
as you are 20 years ago thank you when
the whole world knew you is Lora
LaPlante
[Applause]
your husband's a big producer paramon is
me well I think he'd be very insulted to
have you call him big you've just taken
off 25 pounds leading man now but he has
a producer at Paramount Studios is he
tall
yeah husband about six feet can he hit
hard he's never tried it on me no I was
referring to me I think your husband
producing now well he lasts reduction
was Elephant Walk with Elizabeth Taylor
and Dana Andrews the picture that was
made in salon they took a whole troupe
of players over to salon worked there
about two months the scenery is
magnificent I think scenery that most of
us have never seen I haven't even seen
an elephant and Elizabeth Taylor does
she write on the top of the elephant and
why they call it a house uh
I probably call it you know I don't know
[Music]
you know how much of a student why does
your chief interest in school Henry well
I'm interested in a lot of things that
Fairfax I I guess
I'm interested in athletics I like to
watch the sports and well that's pretty
tiring isn't it
but the thing that I'm most interested
in I had been trying to help organize
the debating team at our school for a
couple of years and nobody ever talked
the wrong people wound what would you
like to be when you finish school if you
ever do
well I'd like to go into politics hukum
header in fact I you want to be a
statesman I think that would be a better
name for it probably well there's quite
a difference between the politician in
the Statesman is there a politician gets
elected and the Statesman gets defeated
you want what do you want to be well on
Alderman
III I'm very interested in being in the
Congress because I feel that there
there's a real opportunity to do things
and there are certainly things that can
be done
oh come now by those boys I'm typing
well I do you know they're only stuck
with 200 million pounds of butter yeah
[Music]
there's one of that big schemes a couple
of others - they have wheat in a
battleship yeah
all I know is why I read it maybe
you win yeah I wish I could continue
this conversation but the time has come
to play you about your life in the race
for the $2,500
the first couple won $27.50 and the
secret word is house now you both know
how to play this game right again I
would like to say if I'm a grouch is
where room if we're lucky enough to win
something I'd like to have my share go
to the motion picture Relief Fund well
that's very nice of you unfortunately
this one influence the quiz however it's
a commendable objective Laura and I'm
proud of you and I wish you weren't
married now let's see how much money
let's see how much money you can make do
select the geography and remember the
mole other question is white the harder
it is talk it over and one answer
between you installed oh I can like my
to know more than thank you okay we'd
like to start with the hundred dollar
question a hundred dollar question yes
why you're his manager he March ahead
under darlin okay what is the capital of
Puerto Rico talk it over
oh I wish I was home I don't San Juan
San Juan is correct occupy starts with
bankroll is now $200
now you have $200 not what you want to
do well the 90 okay
okay 90 90 what country is known as the
pale of the Antilles Antilles I guess
how are your aunt Ellie buddy well as
int honorable Elias and flipper all the
entities we think is Q by Jove it is
cool
$90 listen FiOS before swine and I'm the
pig that know I know it all you want you
can quicken oh yeah yeah you don't have
to proceed oh no I have a good partner
we're not gonna quit let me try the $80
quit already
the Suez Canal connects the
Mediterranean Sea with what other sea
talked it over and Mediterranean deliver
the Pacific I'm depending on you the
Mississippi Cochin Caribbean Caribbean
it's the Red Sea oh I was thinking of
the Panama Canal a shame often do you
think of the Panama Canal
oh wow you lost half your bankroll
you'll still have $145 we'll try for the
70 dollar question alright what is the
name of the storm-tossed southernmost
tip of South America Tierra del Fuego
[Music]
well I've got their Kapaun here but you
apparently you know more about at night
okay and also the boys in the back who
conceived these questions that's good
enough for me
[Applause]
fifteen dollars it kid well thanks and
good luck
Minnesota plumber dealer
[Music]
you
George do your duty tell me whose neck
my Groucho just before we went on the
air our studio audience selected a
fireman his name is Cyril Bennett and
with him is a housewife mrs. Jacqueline
Reiner sin' so folks would you come in
please and meet groucho marx welcome
welcome to you about your life say the
secret word and divide a hundred dollars
it's a common way something you see
every day mr. Sayre Jacqueline rynason a
and mr. Sayle Bennett you're a fireman
tracker I just want to see very special
Asprilla Peter you're a fireman at the
pinochle game going
Jacqueline rynason that's you you're a
very attractive jackal a man called you
jackie jacqueline you may everyone does
everyone does their where you from Jack
oh I was born in Paris France in Paris
France my mother with a war bride in the
First World War
is that so when was that my day was is
1921 you were born in Paris that's right
do you Poli moon well I do bad little
rusty have you tried getting oiled once
in a while
I can meet your Hudson your husband
would you saying was love at first sight
well that depends on how you define love
how the definition for love is fairly
simple it's it's an itching that you can
scratch
[Music]
when you ever here in the 7-year itch
how would you define love jack well I
feel that it's a combination of things
and physical as well as the mental
attraction but I do think the most
important thing is that people feel the
same about basic principles things that
involve integrity honor and
consideration courtesy that's a lot of
them I think so well I guess it is I
guess that's why so many people marry
for money
I'm just an old cynic then so let's get
down to some facts about your job as a
fireman for example how many fires do
you attend in a day I don't go to any
fires
not a very hot fireman
Matt I don't you like to smash furniture
why don't you vote a fire well I'm at
the fire department alarm board that's
the communications center for the fire
department well when you get a call how
long does it take for a fire truck to
respond do they get there the same day
[Music]
well when a fireman receives a alarm he
jumps out of bed slides the pole was on
the truck within 10 seconds five seconds
later he's back upstairs trying to find
his trousers
how does the average citizen act when he
reports the player do they make any
sense or do they just babble oh well far
too often the citizen will call up and
say come quickly my house is on fire
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you said house that's the secret word so
you win $50 and you win $50 Russia
[Music]
[Applause]
we'll tell us some more about what
happens they call you up and say my
house is on fire
yes they'll call up and say come quickly
my house is on fire and then sometimes
they hang up without giving an address
that's a government on you well Jackie
let's get back to you I've discovered
after seven years on this feat here that
every housewife has outside interests
what is yours well for the past 18
months I've been doing everything I can
to help Lightwood become a city liquid
land at a local lake without him pretty
big job how many children do you have so
far
you
[Music]
how do you explain this away well about
18 months ago there was a move to annex
Lakewood to Long Beach and many of us in
the community thought that we were 60
thousand young people intelligent there
certainly should be enough leadership in
our community so that we could have
local self-government so we decided to
do it and we did it sounds like an
unusual place we think it is could you
tell us a little more about it we have
35,000 children whose average ages under
six you have 35,000 children in a total
population of 60,000 that time and you
say Long Beach wanted to annex your town
mm-hmm
well you just keep having children at
that rate and I predict in four more
years
Lakewood will not only annex Long Beach
Leland got the hall of Southern
California
well it's been very interesting talking
to you too and I wish both of you the
best of luck in the future now let's go
you about your life in the race for the
$2,500 the high school student and Laura
LaPlante are leading with $215 let's see
how much money you can make you select a
general information quiz and remember
the more other question is worth the
harder it is you want to start with 10
5,800 take your choice but one answer
between you on everybody yeah 70 in
mathematics what do you call the figure
three decimal point fourteen sixteen
three decimal point one four one six
high that's right what kind you know why
is right you now have one hundred
seventy dollars in your bankroll I don't
have any dollars what do you want to try
sixty what do you call a fatal spot in
the desert no way from me that's true
you now have two hundred thirty dollars
you can quit I'll proceed alright we'll
go ahead fifty mm-hmm what do you call
the track left by a ship passing through
the water
wait that's right you now have $280 what
do you want to try give them quit or go
ahead the party twenty forty forty what
do you call the complete outfit for a
newborn infant you ought to know that oh
yeah lay hat is absolutely correct
and you wind up with $320 thanks and
good luck Minnesota plymouth Island
[Applause]
[Music]
and that means that versus Ryerson them
the firemen with 340 dollars or $20.00
in just one minute get the chance in the
DeSoto Plymouth $2,500 question
all the big news the big news
this year's key total he thought all
with power flight ship just the turn of
the key and you're ready to go no clutch
and no shifting automatic you know
he photo has more more power
[Music]
for the thrill of a rise that will fill
you with my driving solo automatic yes
drive a nudist solo automatic equipped
with power flight America's finest fully
automatic transmission you'll find
driving is easier and far less tiring
because de Soto's fully automatic power
flight transmission was designed to
carry out your sudden orders quickly
smoothly quietly so for a new driving
thrill drive a new DeSoto automatic with
power flight and of its power you're
looking for get behind the wheel of a
desoto firedome the mighty firedome 170
horsepower v8 engine gives you all the
power you can possibly use at the touch
of a tow ready to perform the instant
you call on it
visit your DeSoto Plymouth dealer
tomorrow and treat yourself to the
beauty and luxury of a new DeSoto
automatic available in two great series
the mighty 170 horsepower firedome 8 and
the superb power master six remember
DeSoto puts you ahead automatically and
here comes the winning couple Groucho
all set for the DeSoto Plymouth 2500
other question alright here we go for
$2,500 I'll give you a 15 second to
decide on a single answer between you
think carefully and he's not up in the
audience here it is only one
denomination of the United States
currency has a picture of the White
House on the back of it for $2,500 which
bill is it talking oh yeah fifteen
[Music]
Oh
all right what if what's the answer
YouTube decided upon girl no I'm sorry
at the twenty dollar bill
that means the big question next week
will be worth $3,000 well you lost the
big money but how much they win the quiz
three hundred and twenty dollars left
will do bad congratulations and thanks
to both of you and to all of our
contestants on the show tonight
[Music]